Well,
you know,
one of the things that I have made a mistake about in the past that I just
realized in the last couple of weeks was that,
you know,
people often accused me and they say,
well,
most of the people that listen to you are men.
And I think that,
you know,
when you're accused like that your automatic responses,
while you wouldn't be accused if you weren't doing something wrong,
so the must be something wrong about that.
It's like,
why isn't it 50% women?
And so I've said things like,
well,
you know,
80% of the people who watch youtube videos are man.
And so the fact that 80% of the people who watch my videos are men.
Isn't that surprising given that base rate?
But then about three weeks ago I started thinking,
well,
what the hell am I doing?
It's like,
what?
Is there something wrong with talking to men?
Is that actually a problem?
So like I'm trying to,
I'm trying,
I mean I didn't set out to do that specifically,
but if that's the way it's working out and,
and there is a majority of men coming to my shows say then is that,
why is that all of a sudden supposed to be a bad thing?
I'm asking men to,
you know,
to be more honest and in,
especially in their speech and their thinking and to be more responsible for
themselves and for their family and for their community and to grow up and to
shoulder their burden and to live a responsible and meaningful life and putting
those two things together conceptually.
And it's like,
and then there's an accusation about that as if there's something wrong.
And I thought,
well,
why am I even playing into this?
It's like,
fine,
I'm talking to men,
I'm encouraging them and I am absolutely thrilled.
Like every time someone comes up to me,
um,
and that's happening,
I may be a hundred times a week or something like that and tells me one of these
stories about how they put their life together.
It's like,
I'm absolutely thrilled about that.
And so I don't see,
it's just a sign of how pathological our times have become in some sense that
there would have been any guilt about that to begin with.
Because how was that not a good thing,
man?
It's weird.
Uh,
I think,
uh,
a lot of that has to do with this concept that men are running everything and
that men have this massive advantage.
There's a white male advantage and privilege that we all enjoy and share and
that men have this advantage financially.
There's disparity in terms of the,
the gender gap in pay,
you know,
and,
and income.
And that if you were really a good person,
you would be looking out.
He would be trying to balance that out and then you wouldn't be trying to pump
up the winning team.
So this is where the,
well,
that's it.
And that's part of that narrative that well,
if there's winners there,
there has to be losers.
And the reason that there are losers is because there's winners.
And that's complete bloody nonsense because as far as I'm concerned that,
and I really believe this,
is that every single person who sets out to put themselves together ethically is
a net positive to everyone around them.
There is no downside to that.
You know,
and I,
my book has been criticized by people who've read it very poorly,
especially chapter one when I talk about hierarchies,
that I'm somehow supporting the idea that power in a hierarchy is the right way
to be.
And that's,
there's absolutely nothing in what I've written that suggest that at all.
I'm suggesting that human hierarchies are very complex and that the way that you
win in a human hierarchy is by being competent and reciprocal.
And so,
and so.
I mean,
for example,
even if you're selfish,
let's say you got to think very carefully about what that would mean if you are
selfish and awake because you have to work to take care of yourself and what you
want say in this moment.
But then there's you tomorrow and there's you next week and there's you next
month,
next year,
and 10 years from now.
And when you're old.
So because you're self conscious and because you're aware of the future,
you're actually a community unto yourself.
And if you're a selfish and impulsive,
all that means is that you're serving the person you are right now.
You know in that impulsive way but not the person you're going to be.
And so that's not a good grounds for any sort of ethical behavior.
And I see that if you serve yourself properly,
there is no difference between that and serving your family properly and serving
your community properly.
That those things all mesh in a kind of a harmonious manner.
And one of the things that's really been effective in the lecture tour is a
discussion about that idea and its relationship between the relationship between
that and meaning and responsibility.
Because one of the things that strikes the audience's silent constantly,
cause I'm always listening to them to see,
you know,
when,
when the attention is maximally focused is whenever I point out to people that
the antidote to the meaninglessness of their life and the suffering and the
malevolence that they might be displaying because they're resentful and bitter
about how things have turned out.
The antidote to that is to take on more responsibility for themselves and for
other people.
And that that's aspirational,
which is Kinda cool.
You know,
the conservative types,
the duty types,
and I'm not complaining about them,
you know,
they're always basically saying,
well this is how you should act.
Because in some sense that's your duty,
right?
That's how a good citizen would act.
And that's a reasonable argument.
But the case that I've been making is more that,
well there is a,
there is value distinctions between things.
Some things are worth doing and some things aren't.
And you can kind of discover what that is for yourself and then you should aim
at the things that are most worth doing.
And what you'll find if you watch carefully,
is that the things that you find worth doing are almost always associated with
an increase in responsibility.
Because if you think about the people you admire,
for example,
you spontaneously admire people and that's a manifestation of the instinct.
Imitate.
Again,
people are very imitative.
You don't admire people who don't take care of themselves.
Like unless there's something wrong with you,
you,
you at least want an admirable person to be accountable for themselves.
And then if they've got something left over so they can be accountable for their
family while then that's a net plus,
obviously that's someone you think is solid and then maybe they take care of
some more people.
They have a business or they're involved in the community in some positive way.
You see,
well,
that's a person who's pattern of being is worth imitating and so on.
That's all associated with responsibility and it's so interesting because it's
as if it's as if everybody kind of knows this,
but that it hasn't crystallized.
It's like,
well,
you should be responsible because that's what a good citizen is.
It's not,
no,
no.
You should be responsible because you need to have a deep meaning in your life
to offset the suffering so you don't get bitter.
And the way you do that is to bear a heavy load,
you know,
to get yourself in check for you now and for you in the future.
And then to do the same for your family and your community.
And that there's real nobility in that and there's real meaning and more.
The other thing that I've been suggesting to people,
and I also believe this,
is that,
and I think that the guys that have come to talk to me,
especially the ones that have had real la real rough lives,
they really understand this.
If you don't get your act together and you let yourself slide,
then what kind of moves in to take the place of what you could have been is
something that's really not good at all.
So it's not only that if you're living a like a dissolute life,
that you're not aiming at anything positive and so you don't have any real
meaning and you're subsumed by anxiety and all of that and hopelessness.
But something kind of hellish moves in there to,
to,
to occupy that place.
And so then you end up making things worse.
And when,
you know,
one of the things I learned about studying totalitarian systems,
whether they were on the right or the left,
was that part of the reason that the totalitarian horrors of the 20th century
manifested themselves was because average people didn't take on the proper
responsibility.
They shut their eyes when they're,
I should have been open,
even though they knew it and they did,
and said things they knew they shouldn't have done and said,
and that was what supported those horrible systems.
So,
you know,
if you don't get your act together,
then you leave a little space for hell.
And I really believe that.